Now that you have a product idea, it is
time to move to the validation process.
Remember that a lot of ideas look
great on paper, but fail in real life.
Validating your idea
could help you determine
if your idea is as good as it sounds.
>> As you validate your idea,
you may find that your idea
isn't as good as you thought.
In that case,
you might need to generate new ideas, or
combined new ones with new ones.
Just be careful that you don't get
stuck at this point in the course.
We want you to put something
in front of users and
understand the process of going
from an idea to a product.
>> One way to validate your idea,
is to do user research.
In the next videos, you will learn how
to do user research from Tomer Sharon,
our researcher in Google New York.